[Music]
my favorite part of this marvel intro to
a hawkeye show is that you have to play
a game of where's clinto to even locate
him he flashes in the m here for like
half a second and this is his [ __ ]
show living in the past i'm sure they're
there but in this shot i can't see the
hind legs of this giraffe which makes me
think of how a two-legged giraffe would
basically look like a really tall person
without arms and with a horse face and
spotted fur but my point is two-legged
giraffe mommy said things don't just
fall from the sky well blow out your
marvel reference bingo card cause you
can mark off invasion of new york on it
we're only two minutes in and i'm
already just the people disappeared in
the blip and a free space away from
calling bingo i bet she didn't know i
could do this
impressing your children with a choking
hazard this bisected narwhal why are all
the animals in this room terrifying me
daddy where are you well she literally
just said okay i'm going i'll start so
maybe start there okay so i've been
working on this new impression and this
seems as good a time as any to try it
out
generic bad guy soldiers whose abilities
and shortcomings are never explained
nailed it attempting to make hawkeye
look cool i'm still the luckiest woman
in the world
because i have the greatest little girl
in the world and you didn't seem to like
your husband very much and were weirdly
jealous of the bond he and kate had so
winning one minute and 29 seconds of
opening titles we're watching kate train
in this opening but did you see how
quickly those two arrows hit that target
the only way she's firing off arrows
that accurately and that quick at this
point in her training is if someone
skull matrixed archery directly into her
wait is that blood spatter if you're
getting blood spatter from a strike
you're fencing wrong present day come on
guys we've been through this if i watch
this 40 years from now will it take
place in 2061 unless of course you're
playing into the christmas theme and
mean present day which honestly is still
too vague so merry christmas here's your
present if you get caught you're
definitely gonna be kicked off the
archery team which brings the question
why are they on the phone right now
kate's friends can see her up there and
them being on the phone doesn't change
what she's going to do probably isn't
anyone that will hear them talking this
late at night but why take a chance plus
kate left her coat discarded on the
stairs so i'm pretty sure covert is on
top of the ring the bell raid bet
priority list i know she's an expert
archer and all that comes with it but
i'm still giving this a this works
because just like the dennis leary song
says i'm an [ __ ]
yo yo
alright that's uh that's not great no
it's not but honestly if the weight of
your little tennis bald arrow is doing
this that bell was a stiff breeze away
from pulling a full hunchback and notre
damning itself anyway
setting your action series at christmas
time without shane black involved iron
man 3 wasn't that bad i mean
yeah okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
but also episode does not contain rogers
the musical in its entirety honey i know
i know what happens talking during a
live performance
why is the shawarma visit even mentioned
in this musical it seems like the
musical referencing the movie we saw not
the actual events as they happened in
this world you're telling me the
avengers casual dining experience at
schwarma somehow made headlines enough
that it's a key punchline in this song
reading while peeing keep your attention
on the job at hand so i don't have to
step in your unsupervised flonin k clint
also why is thanos lowercase but right
is capitalized getting the grammar
correct is the first rule of urinal
graffiti if you can't do it right don't
do it at all kids
this whole thing is a bit ridiculous
isn't it still can't believe he was an
avenger would be excellent at tv sins
why is everyone singing and dancing
about everything musicals vera farmiga
isn't ghost hunting in this scene i'm
about to replace an irreplaceable clock
tower but if it's irreplaceable then how
will you replace it do words mean
nothing anymore we cannot be late so
go change
meet us at the hotel and we'll talk
there okay i haven't actually told you
the hotel we'll be at but i'm sure if
you get in the cab and ask for the hotel
the rich people are at they'll know
exactly where to take you mom is going
say hi putting your phone on speaker in
a public place no one else wants to hear
your conversation hawkeye no one
christmas movie marathon i'm sitting
christmas movie marathons for
necessitating conversations on what
constitutes a christmas movie you know
what i've decided there's no such thing
as a christmas movie there are movies
that take place around christmas movies
that mention christmas and maybe even
movies you like to watch around
christmas i'm half tempted to start a
debate about what movies are thursday
movies just to show you all how
ridiculous you sound it's necessary
you're safe in our city and put us in
financial ruin for the next few years
with all the destruction you helped
cause but we ignore that bart
hi heck of a party huh
rude dogs sure is nice of people in
shows and movies to leave doors wide
open when they're talking about stuff so
our characters can get the info they
need it's so against human nature yet
they manage it every time also between
this scene and the one at the beginning
i hope kate's superhero name ends up
being the eavesdropper cause that is
definitely a power she wields lucky for
kate she has on the exact same suit the
wait staff is wearing at the event how
else would she accomplish the worst
infiltration attempt ever why don't we
leave eleanor alone your goat i don't
know if mustachio here ends up being a
bad guy or not but if he is then here's
a sin for the show making it this
obvious however if jack ends up not
being a bad guy then here's a sin for
the show making it this obvious and not
following through
you heard me we have four champagne
glasses we don't have four champagne
glasses another important conversation
she just happens to find kate
accidentally herself into plot relevant
information like she's the bow and arrow
version of inspector freaking clouseau
come on ladies and gentlemen this sword
belonged to the infamous ronin but that
would be nearly impossible to prove
right i'm no auction expert but i'm
guessing proof is important when
assessing the value let's go
and the director said he's wearing a
mask so the apple's probably out but
let's have him say the word bro it will
accomplish the same thing case
conveniently clears its contents for
kate to cleverly clothe her core
conspicuously do you know who i am
cliche
missing only exists in case you ever
wondered what the movie cocktail would
have looked like if marvel directed it
if the character lifts masks so we can
recognize them later even though there's
no practical reason to do so wasn't
enough show has his buddies yell out his
name for a double portion of audience
spoon feeding it's a little late for tv
guys i've got a pack but dad
how would we get in the blatant news
position without it on huh dad huh
cutting to the worst scene from avengers
end game well except there was that
scene where the hulk was eating a lot of
food and that scene where thor had a
beer gut and fine cutting to a top 10
worst scene from avengers in game are we
all ready to admit in game wasn't that
good i look forward to the pleasant
enlightening discussions that will be
happening in the comments section
welcome to my apartment having an
apartment in new york city when you
already have a dorm room on campus the
sin as always is rich kids
you like pizza that sound you just heard
it was the internet yelling pizza dog
because it's from the comics and by
internet i mean a few people that
actually knew the reference and then 100
times that many people who just heard
about it on twitter and want to pretend
it's meaningful to them as well so they
don't feel left out also feeding a dog
pizza but then giving him no water
monogrammed butterscotch kate doesn't
get kicked out of her school even though
she destroyed a historical bell tower
but wants to bark at armon's choices on
how he promotes his privilege pot
calling something something kate
did you see how badly she missed him
there slow that down so we can all
marvel at it
she's a good foot and a half from his
face how do you even include this shot
why doesn't she keep running i was
getting in a car with no key to start it
helpful at all in this scenario
ex hawkina
come on being this upset you can't hit
someone let me decide what i care about
i just wanted to see the pizza dog again
but no six days into christmas and we're
gonna fill it with a lot of christmas
activities
thanks previously on segment now i know
the gingerbread house will play a
prominent role in this episode because
you reminded us of it spoiler culture
has gone too far wasn't all of this at
the end of the last episode it's like
the 90 seconds of previously on before
the opening logos wasn't enough so you
had to do another 20 seconds after them
for a total of two and a half full
minutes before we even get to any new
content a decision made even worse by
the fact that this episode released at
the same time as episode 1. we don't
need all this refresher of something we
just saw i don't know who herman hired
for his graphics but this is a terrible
representation of a piece of pizza come
to herman's where you can get a single
giant pepperoni a random mushroom in
what might be toenail clippings on every
slice i uh started taking martial arts
when i was five wow
it's like a year ago hayley steinfeld's
a 25 year old woman so you can just go
ahead and [ __ ] all the way off with that
condescending noise so that that's how
you operate you're just constantly
looking for things that are suspicious
or weird actual footage of friends and
family attempting to understand my job
somehow makes its way into the show um
you know some some people have actually
called me the world's greatest archer
being arrogant enough to play people
have been saying bragg oh he's not my
dog dog napping so what all did you do
in this suit that is a personal question
sir you're kind of my favorite avenger
are you okay by the way clearly not did
you hear what you just said there's at
least a concussion at play here the
tracks just must have followed you from
the auction to where i found you which
reminds me how did hawkeye find her in
the first place does he have tracking
tech left over from avenger days
announcing yourself five full seconds
before attacking if they didn't wear the
tracksuits we could have gone with
cliched bad guys who make sure our
heroes have time to crack a joke and get
out of the way suit mafia my favorite
part of the episode is watching hawkeye
and this kid with a [ __ ] bow just
casually walk down the fire escape in
plain view of the tracksuiters and the
pizza joint owners i mean we don't see
when they descend from above and come
out from the front of the building but
that has to be what happened right why
else would they be walking in the front
of the building like this
is is he swiping all these supplies for
the single cut on his forehead one tube
must be enough and why does she need
this much rubbing alcohol this is too
much even for people who are wanting to
make their own hand sanitizer stocking
your goldfish near the wound closure
tape why yes clint you may enter my
apartment she says to clint while
currently standing in someone else's
apartment without permission
good thing hawkeye knew about the
age-old tradition of firemen leaving
their jackets directly by open fire
truck doors and their helmets on the
front bumper it's that hero college
education finally paying off
i don't want to spend the next half hour
researching whether or not fire
departments allow personalized stickers
on their work vehicles so instead i'm
going to send this plot convenience
sticker and send anyone who would want
to advertise their larp nerdness so
boldly since when did everybody start
saying i love you to everybody all the
time cynicism this much first aid chaos
for that little cut you did it all wrong
let me fix it is the idea that after
years of combat training kate wouldn't
know how to apply a band-aid to her
forehead correctly way to undermine the
intellect and basic problem-solving
skills of your brilliant female lead i'm
just gonna rip it off like a band-aid
okay it is a band-aid there is no way
that this man just typed nyc la erpers
by tapping his thumbs in the same place
on the keyboard over and over again
let's fix this let's figure out what he
really wrote
well that's dumb the most miraculous
thing about the ronin gear is that it
magically fits every body type head in
the mode eat your heart out
again
fine we'll fix this one too
no donuts buddy forbidding donuts i may
be an idiot but i got seniority middle
management this is about the ninja no
it's not about the ninja lying to your
children these two events have officials
wondering if indeed the ronin has
returned to new york city we're now two
for two on episodes with forced news
position i'm not counting my arrows
before they quiver but hawkeye may be
trying to shoot the moon here and get
news position into every episode and
it's risky because it's a sin every time
but if they pull it off we'll be forced
to take 50 sins off in the final episode
we'll keep you updated you're just not
going to listen to me are you why would
she she's not a child and she barely
knows hawkeye if the show thinks that
his clout should weigh in on his ability
to boss other people around they should
have done a better job at making us
believe that anyone gives a [ __ ] about
who hawkeye even is go get changed
you look silly easy there clint you just
combined a man orders a woman around
with a woman should look a certain way
if you aren't careful we're gonna think
you're a legitimate [ __ ] instead of
this weird half-hole thing the show
seems to be trying to do what am i
selling then huh it's certainly not
halloween costumes the toys off the
shelf inspiration but also pretty much
solely for the halloween costumes and
toys off the shelf because disney okay
what are you wearing
oh they said um
a friend being ashamed to admit your
friends with david s pumpkins she feels
threatened by me and you know what
i can understand why is it because
you're a one note character that's
painted so thin you can still see the
drywall behind you because
and if you break the rules
it's gonna get real messy but why would
hawkeye care about what the police
officers and firefighters think if he
breaks the larp rules or is he afraid
they'd beat him up for disrupting their
adult playtime for a very real threat is
no one allowed to be an actual adult
during larp time is it a you have to be
in character until midnight situation
because those rules are broken
immediately when grylls has a quick chat
with hawkeye out of character and they
work it out certainly everyone here
would be all about helping hawkeye solve
a real threat but the show's got a larp
i guess so your scrota tells your
character's mission by god's bones look
at that sarting scroll it's like a heavy
duty parchment with flame detailed edges
and fancy calligraphy instructions and
you're saying every player gets one of
these who's financing this buffer elon
musk what are the rules here can
everyone swarm one person and eliminate
them everyone seemed paired up a moment
ago so how do you know when to switch to
free-for-all i'm asking because the
show's confusing me not because i want
to do it or anything so is it just like
a torso hit that takes you out like when
would i know how to like fake an injury
and then like fall to a knee before
rising up and shoving my pretend sword
through my enemy's thigh in this really
dumb confusing game you're a superhero
in real life discounting that you are a
real-life superhero as a firefighter and
i fought thanos yeah and i'm sure that
after i spun out and told my car trying
to avoid an idiot driver that the bug
that happened to hit my rear windshield
right before the spin reveled at the
chaos he thought he caused too hawkeye's
adorable again
see you tomorrow
the phone makes the hang-up noise but
kade didn't hang up and neither did the
officer so who's the third person on the
line and why is it pizza dog
you must drink the ritualistic portion
it is a bottle event has the cash for
multiple banners tents props and
costumes but when the call came through
for a bottle they were all like what do
you think we're made of money you mime
that [ __ ] wendy can't have that show up
on my credit card no they they will
charge which brings the question how was
hawkeye not charged to play already can
anyone walk in and laugh for free until
midnight how are funds collected how is
the group funded who is paying to rent
out a spot in central park boring i
already knew this was coming because of
the previously on and now it means
nothing to me okay all she said was why
not that's not a convincing argument
that's not an argument at all i was
going to say norma bates would be
excellent at tv sins and such but then i
thought is why not an argument so then i
decided that actually it could be a
valid argument and that she's wrong here
and therefore not excellent at tv sins
but since i've already started sinning
this i might as well go ahead and give
the sin anyway because well
why not is is this my first rich person
has fencing gear at the ready cliche how
many people get murdered by a sword each
year in new york well technically swords
are classified as cutting instruments
and lumped with knives and such because
let's face it knives are really just
tiny swords so quick search says about
30 of murders in new york are by swords
of varying sizes so maybe just open up
google for a second okay before throwing
jack's good name under the bus
oh
no not a simple butterscotch that was at
a dead person's house one time and could
have been handed to jack 12 different
non-nefarious ways kate bishop
not keepish keep bishop this guy bro
bishop is not guy did hawkeye just take
a right turn into deadpooly and
silliness cause the tone whiplash is
real bro and rinner could really work on
his ryan reynolds impersonation
bro i found her and he knows this how he
can't see her face and only moments ago
he thought kate was a dude
whoa a person that's probably important
in the comics but i don't know just
ended the episode by breaking the fourth
wall and looking right at me however
could i stop watching now
come on i know right this is essentially
a previously on previously on segment
we're pretty tired of it too mr renner
when does the madness end drawing a
dragon with boobs crossing your legs
like this shouldn't the karate
instructor tell maya that her fists are
too close to her body in this stance i
mean i know she could take me regardless
but that's bad form i was prepared to
send this show for taking this long for
echo to appear or maybe send media in
general for dragging their feet on
planning an amazing character like echo
and center stage but see the problem is
that i [ __ ] love watching this
diverse powerhouse of a woman burst onto
the scene and i can't help but give sins
back sorry to let you down sinners this
is a big moment for representation and
deserves recognition
i was about to clear your name from the
suit
until you decided to crash through the
skylight yeah but why not give her a
heads up on what your plans were when
you were last together instead of the
this is probably the last time we meet
here's my phone number for emergency
spiel from the previous episode you
could have given kate a little more
insight and then maybe she doesn't make
this mistake also what do you mean she
decided to crash through the skylight
kate is overconfident but i have a hard
time believing she'd opt for a
purposeful roof crash you good kate is
snarky and rebellious and overall a
delight to watch but does she fear any
consequences sure the mobsters are
humorous and may be dumb to the point of
being approachable but there are so many
instances of her not valuing her own
life which makes her yet another level
of unrelatable discount corey feldman
is it normally from high shelving units
directly into freestanding wooden
splinter shelves i've never tried but
seems like there were other directions
clint could have aimed this convenient
and well-placed trampoline followed by
this convenient and well-placed quiver
of arrows near this convenient bow
followed by a convenient pit of
convenient balls and i'm done i get he's
done with straight up killing people but
he could have shot maya in the shoulder
or leg he has no issues doing that to
her henchmen hawkeye shoots an arrow
while dramatically falling cliche also
diving into a children's stinky ball pit
without fear or reservation hawkeye is
shooting people in arms and shoulders
and hands and that's fine but wouldn't
the bad guys still be able to crawl to
their weapons i mean the show won't let
them so that clinton cate can escape but
in real life i'm pretty sure at least
one of the henchmen would still be a
threat if the goal is to kick kazi over
just boot him in the poop rather than
swinging around the thingy sure is cool
of everyone to suddenly be not so
injured altogether at the same time this
driving sequence which we're witnessing
almost the entire time from the car is
brilliantly executed and yes i'm well
aware of the similar sequence in the
classic noir gun crazy but even if this
is an homage to that it's a
well-constructed one i love it how many
we got
but we suddenly do not have a part of
the car that was here a moment ago i'm
sure that car door piece has been
removed for the ensuing stun portion of
this amazing car scene but if its
absence doesn't bother me throughout the
next few minutes this long shot is fun
to watch i'm in the car i'm riding
around i'm invested i'm wondering why
the car in front of you is running a red
light we're going to die
hit the wheels with the putty arrow
might have been a good idea to let kate
know that this was the arrow she was
using and what to do with it before she
fired hawkeye really sucks at giving
useful information out at the time it's
actually needed there are four arrows
more dangerous than that one i'm sorry
you said [ __ ] i just murdered people
wrong trying to out lethal lethal weapon
with all this senseless christmas tree
murder here acid arrows drop the stop
legs or you know wait until the car
catches up with you and shoot them at
the tires or engine to stop them but
sure stop lights considering kate has no
understanding of each arrow's abilities
i find that ochi calmly aims for the
dashboard of the car without fear of the
possibility that her close proximity
could place her in a range of maiming
death or dismemberment i mean yay it's
just a poof cloud and everyone important
survives episode four but she shouldn't
know that
and for some reason kate is immediately
fired upon by all of the people who
wanted to kill them only moments ago i
can't tell which is more unlikely that
pizza dog hasn't shut all over the
apartment by now or that kate and clint
somehow know how to synchronize their
impossible leap turn grab stunt with
zero practice what is maya shooting at
kate and clint are falling down not
forward she should be running to the
side of the bridge naming down see there
were peas in the freezer and kate didn't
need to put a box of pizza on her head
last episode she had more logical
choices only seven seconds pass from the
time kate begins to write this until she
shows that it reads says it's okay if
you can't be home for christmas and
there's just no way she wrote this
legibly that fast how could they not opt
for trust a bro moving co it rhymes i am
disappointed but why are they keeping
the toys or better question why were
toys left behind when the store boasted
total stock liquidation
i'm often asked if you could learn any
language instantly what language would
it be i always say mandarin seeing this
though i'm thinking that instantly
learning asl would be so [ __ ] cool
damn it marvel now i'm conflicted and
i'm blaming you this phone has a rokit
logo down here and i have a sinking
feeling that's an easter egg which
reminds me that i want to know but i
also don't want to do the work to figure
it out you know i really hate marvel for
doing their job so well i know this may
sound weird but
i've dreamed of this for as long as i
can remember telling someone you just
met a day ago that you've always dreamed
of being his partner no not weird at all
my dad was
fearless who would name their child
fearless i'm not a role model
disrespecting charles barkley's wishes
to not be a role model by making him
your role model for not wanting to be a
role model you uh you care to elaborate
not really and then five seconds later
hawkeye elaborates despite saying he
didn't care to stop sending mixed
messages just be an ass you try to step
your mom's fiance in the face cause he
has everything to gain from her mom's
death these two idiots continue to have
a conversation about all this inside a
taxi no way in hell she knew how to
spell qazi's last name on the first try
nope damn you previously awning did we
really need to see the slaughtering of
slinky arm santa again what the hell is
going on
and why is there an avenger in my dining
room where oh he'll never get anything
out of him
see cb1 has trouble opening up kate was
fun at first but she may now be the most
annoying marvel character to date and
damn it i think jar jar may even be part
of this universe now
t slurpers just go with me here jack is
obsessed with swords kate is obsessed
with hawkeye and eleanor is so invested
in kate's being safely separated from
clint that i doubt anyone would take
their eyes off of clint long enough for
him to do anything other than get his
coat and get the [ __ ] out how did he get
out with the sword but what i can do is
ensure your daughter stay safe he cannot
she's awfully composed around her own
idol if i haven't met huey lewis i'd be
a wreck comparing hawkeye to huey lewis
the man wrote back in time damn it
kate's always been confident
never had to worry about her on that
front wait they're having this
conversation while she is sitting right
there jack now speaks sings the words to
the christmas song by nat king cole and
is just off beat enough to make me want
to rip off my own ears and shove them
down his generically european sounding
throat and a happy new year
you know what they say
life is shown
you never know what you're gonna get did
he just butcher the life is like a box
of chocolates quote from forrest gump i
don't care if this is a deliberate
character quirk thanos was right dust
this fool no
that can't be right that someone in this
family decided to stop centering the
center stocking hanging on the fireplace
yeah they did that and they should be
punished also hanging your stocking
directly over an actual fire and screw
you tv show if you expect me to believe
that this fire guard is going to do
shittily dit to stop this festively
flamey foo bar i guess
getting laughed at my family is better
than being alone in the holidays right
putting aside the fact that being
comfortable with your own company has
inherent value in itself the real sin
here is that some people have no option
but to be alone during the holidays i'm
certain this was a very unhelpful
reminder in what is a valid piece of
escapism risk yahtzee stratego
excitement in previous episodes we've
seen hawkeye get first aid supply so why
is he risking the defrosting of all this
fruity goodness instead of buying an
actual cold compress he knew where the
mission was going why isn't he getting
stocked up ahead of time anyway
[Music]
he is squatting in an apartment why is
he confidently answering the door lay
low you bozo hey
i'm all for casual responses to
non-life-threatening situations but
pizza dog just mouthed the entire upper
layer of cheez-its that deserves at the
very least a more emphatic no also
please stop giving the dog human food
they'd have just named him purina dog
none of this would have been a problem
believing die hard is a christmas movie
believing die hard isn't a christmas
movie having an opinion anywhere on the
is die hard a christmas movie spectrum
instead of just [ __ ] enjoying die
hard for the masterpiece that it is
after all he's lost i'd expect hawkeye
to be more inclined to drink this slushy
treat from a container made of his own
scrotum than choose to use this thanos
was right mug see the tree covers the
parts that won't come off yeah from the
exact angle that the camera happens to
be viewing it from right now but not
from the rest of the damn apartment what
happens when the tree comes down kate
what then you movie poster mauling
monster have you ever heard of boomerang
arrows what why would i ever want to use
a boomerang arrow hawkeye would be the
green arrow at tv sins you got to show
me how you just did that asking a
superhero their secrets oh never mind
it's only hawkeye that's why i'm here i
can't go home till i fix it hawkeye is
referring to all the people he killed
his ronin so i have to ask how will it
ever be over there's always a chance
that some dead assassin's son or
sister will come after him and his
family for revenge or a fist-chined
alien or [ __ ] michael clark duncan
the point i'm getting at here is that i
don't see how clint can ever be
confident that his family will ever be
safe from hawkeye and ronan's past you
should get some rest
you got a big day tomorrow no she
doesn't what happened to but what i can
do is ensure your daughter stay safe
you're going to include her in the
mission just because she brought over
pizza in a christmas tree why is she
even sleeping here shouldn't her mother
be expecting her back home if you want
your two main characters to play
together just let them [ __ ] do it and
stop setting up all these [ __ ]
obstacles that you then ignore 10
minutes later previously on infinity war
part 2. you know i like to think of them
more
as our arrows yes and hawkeye fans think
he deserves his place in the avengers we
all have our delusions kate
yeah but what kind of ice wall if the
roof is high enough a wall won't help
your defense you need to be certain the
wall is higher than the roof go with ice
dome or at the very least ice shield so
that you can be mobile with your
defenses amateur i don't mean interrupt
you
oh this is you guys are
dedicated uh hawkeye sent me here on
official avengers business i'm uh his
partner's best friend kate the outright
hypocrisy of kate turning her nose up at
the larpers while simultaneously having
a total lack of awareness of the fantasy
world in which she herself is choosing
to live better as al's beth of deep dale
bragging about being from deep dale
which is basically like bragging that
you're from northampton i can probably
help you out wait what kate is openly
asking for an illegal favor in front of
a group of people she doesn't even know
and the officer is immediately on board
is this another person i'm supposed to
be excited to meet and don't know it
fine i'm sitting larping all over again
to feel better about this nonsensical
moment if you make it worth my while
this is a request from the dam avengers
and these guys are pulling a dormammu i
know new yorkers have a reputation but
surely the avengers have banked enough
goodwill in the last decade to cover
fetching a few arrows i know he doesn't
like his attention that's for sure
hawkeye plays the pronoun game for this
entire car chat for no other reason than
to keep us guessing about who the big
boss is which means it must be somebody
we know already or they just go ahead
and say their name right where's tom
holland i need some answers
looking for this
or maybe it's the box cutter under the
seat kazi has a box cutter hidden under
the seat and a knife in the sun shade
but not a single weapon actually on his
person hey can i have my gun back
yeah what do you think i was relieved
that hawkeye didn't give the gun back
right up until the point he threw it in
a random direction i don't care if he
unloaded it first he still left a gun
somewhere in the middle of a used car
lot where it can be found by literally
anybody why not take it with him he
doesn't even have to use it or does the
mere presence of a gun maybe make him
realize how futilely ridiculous his
archery superpower is i asked you to
simply retrieve my arrows
not stage a play there are times when i
remember that glenn is an [ __ ] and
this moment is one of them he did send
kate to a larp group what did he think
was gonna happen we've gotta we gotta go
we're in this together right well you
know what are you gonna have to change
no you're not and no she does not you're
supposed to be keeping her safe yeah the
lights no movement title of my
sex tape so if you see anything out here
just give me a second okay all right
character continues to have conversation
with person who they should have heard
leave but somehow did not cliche good
evening sir
can i help you with your bags this is
i'm sure hilarious to somebody but did
kate really need to help this man in
order to use the elevator all she really
needed to do was follow him into the
building once he opened the door does
she think the grocery bags are hiding
her bow and arrows i think she thinks
the grocery bags are hiding her bow and
arrows
this side explaining elevator capacity
says children count as people
[Laughter]
nonsense i was talking to an avenger
where there are like strobe lights
attached to the wall it's robot what do
you mean
i don't know
yeah what do you see so we're just gonna
move on from the flashy strobe lights
that only started their strobie flashing
after kate walked in yeah i'm sure it's
absolutely nothing definitely not a
silent alarm or anything like that okay
get out of there now what
why that light's an alarm it's a silent
alarm for people that can't hear well
duh
wait am i smarter than an avenger oh
sorry never mind it's just hawkeye
convenient accidental zipline pinging is
all of the convenient types of
accidental convenience
audible head whoosh outside of a looney
tunes cartoon is extremely audible and
outside of a looney tunes cartoon
hawkeye the show where characters just
randomly discard firearms to be found by
any member of the public responsibility
sold separately
[Music]
what tell me these aren't the most
pointless restraints you've ever seen
what good are they if you can pull them
off after a couple of seconds okay okay
maybe it's because maya has some
enhanced durability or strength that we
haven't been told about
apparently not
if this was the only place that kate was
strapped in then she is 100 swapping
notes with gwen stacy right now instead
of surviving this
does kate know what the trick arrow will
do before she shoots it no but they're
the holy arrows of convenience so yay
plot [ __ ] is happening
ten zins for not acknowledging the
flubber that is clearly lining maya's
damn boots go home cake
it's over with two episodes left we know
damn well that it isn't i don't care if
you split your four and a half hour
movie into six 45-minute episodes
sticking this at the end of the fourth
part still earns you a third act
conflict cliche and double screw you for
making me do any math he had widows
implanted all over the world previously
on black widow
wait
[Music]
anna is supposed to be a black widow and
yet she manages to miss elena from this
close the only thing this needless
saucer sacrifice will serve to do is
piss off the british well i suppose
every cloud also elena stands here
waiting for the action to pop off and
then steps in with a gun to the face
which looks interesting but makes no
sense when you consider that all she
needs to do is spray this deadly
assassin in the face with an antidote
and this would be
over hit her with the epidural antidote
to what who are these people and what
are they doing in my hawkeye show what
is happening it's as if i'm missing an
entire movie's worth of context here
look what you did to my rug title of my
sex tape twenty thousand dollars down
the drain thanks so we're just throwing
out rugs rather than having them
professionally cleaned now you can be
rich but don't be wasteful wait this is
your house
how can you afford all of this well sh
what a brave soul i mean can you imagine
asking someone a sexist like this i mean
asking sexist a question like this i
mean sex is someone a sexist sexist
sexist
just a moment ago elena had short nails
and now her nails are longer and
manicured so did her hands age five
years and visit the nail salon wait why
would elena be seeing any of the
surrounding redusting it's a great
visual for us the audience but shouldn't
she just puff back into existence like
everything already redecorated itself
elena yep that's black widow assassin
trained in the arts of murder who
happens to be pointing a weapon at a
child and clearly mellow man yes
something acid trippy happened with the
whole house changing around her and yes
there could be dangerous folks around
but this is a child and a man that can
barely make eye contact lower your
weapon i got married
we adopted three years ago it's been
amazing but what about the rug in the
name of clara prast this is an
overabundance of greenery we've got four
potted plants on this shelf situation
one down here by the floor one on this
table some rose bush looking [ __ ]
under this lamp and two actual trees on
either side of the window if this is a
backdoor poison ivy prequel i will lose
my [ __ ] other bucket now you decide to
do the credits in previous leons which
makes the flow of this episode so far a
flashback referencing the film you're
presuming i've seen a jump to the
present day to make last episode's
reveal make sense then into opening
credits then back to last week's episode
again to set me up for the three minutes
that are left of this episode awesome
and why are you wearing your archery
suit i want to believe that these
pockets are here for a reason you know
for keys or a smartphone can we just see
a massive rectangle phone thingy in a
pocket to justify this pocket please or
maybe the outline of car keys look at me
you're the only thing that matters
why are people putting the sticky part
of the band-aid on the wound some people
question whether or not kate's mom is a
bad guy in disguise i vote she's evil
with my chief and foremost bit of
evidence being the way she applied the
band-aid to her daughter's forehead
bishop
hi
[Laughter]
florence pew [ __ ] rules are you
really not hungry that fight was so long
i really would recommend eating
something now because this teta tet's on
for all the quippy amounts of all of the
forever until the end of some time you
have one fork i'm one person that is not
a valid reason for only owning one fork
does kate really want to spend her life
cleaning the same fork over and over
again immediately after every use by
that logic why does she have four bowls
and at least three glasses here time
travel aliens in wizards i can just
about buy but this is some real [ __ ]
hey gorillas it's clint can i come up so
he won't put kate in danger but he will
put grills in danger noted i love
american christmas is the tree
the presents the super-powered reindeer
rudolph i was ready to send the fact
that rudolph isn't american but turns
out he originated on the pages of a
coloring book created for a
chicago-based retailer in the 1930s so
here's a sin for illinois instead
are you in new york to talk to clint i'm
here to kill him i mean is this a shock
decade after the rooftop fight where
elena was you know trying to kill him
okay wow that was
very russian that's racist he's still an
avenger okay now i'm lost i thought we
were talking about hawkeye it will not
be difficult for me to complete this
assignment wait a minute somebody hired
you to kill him is it a bird is it a
plane no it's super kate making yet
another unwarranted building-sized
deductive leap into the truth with her
plot-powered snow boots yelena
describing her mission to kill hawkeye
as an assignment does not necessarily
mean that she has an employer for all
kate knows elena has assigned this
mission to herself which would make
sense given its revengey nature why does
an employer have to be involved at all
unless you've read the script
[Music]
so we're just not using doors anymore
all guys are staying in a hotel for
christmas then take my couch and that
couch is better than an entire hotel
room to yourself how exactly especially
if you lay on the couch like this spines
are not replaceable damn it
just because the dog's name is pizza dog
doesn't mean he should only ever be fed
pizza i mean one of the cinema sins
writers has a dog named after a candy
bar and you don't see her shoving twix
bars down the poor animal's throat
anymore
stupid orange rock belittling your best
friend's sacrifice by calling the soul
stone a stupid orange rock i'm so sorry
for what i'm about to do walk through a
crowded street with your hood up and
head down without your hearing device
increasing the probability of running
into people or missing pretty major cues
from your peripheral vision yeah you
should be sorry [ __ ] character is
somehow inspired to take action by
staring nostalgically at all of the
nostalgia cliche i know you said it's
over but it's not
not for me disrespecting someone else's
desire for distance by stalkingly
inserting yourself into their world
without apology this isn't over barton
i'm gonna find you directly followed by
an admission of intent to actually stalk
them the mailbox is full and cannot
accept any messages at this time what
kind of talk tease voicemail waits until
after you've recorded your message to
tell you the mailbox is full thankfully
this car was installed with special aero
grabbing safety glass for maximum
dramatic effect it's just a matter of
time before the big guy gets involved
jesus no one saw that plot twist coming
jesus is the big guy of hawkeye what a
reveal
wait what listen my confusion about this
whole thing could have been easily
avoided if people would stop playing the
pronoun game listen you didn't call
looking for permission and you don't
need it for me so i trust your judgment
one of my favorite things about this
show is laura and clint's relationship
instead of being a disappointed
background character that bogs down the
story laura understands the value of
what he's doing trust him to make the
right calls and supports him where she
can not every relationship has to be
about conflict people okay
let's talk yes let's talk about why
hawkeye decided it was necessary to
announce his presence by unsheathing his
sizable sword instead of just
immediately knocking qazi out so the
baseball bad guy is taken out toward the
left of the screen and then background
tracksu guy goes to the right
immediately after how did ronin get to
both men so quickly well before that
very interesting question has a moment
to matter imagine dragon's lovers
rapidly ripped over the hood of the car
back towards the left my point is roman
is one man he's not freaking
nightcrawler he cannot be this powerful
wait is ronin nightcrawler for some
reason maya who has so far seemed to be
pretty switched on decides to unload her
entire clip before getting anything
close to a clear shot on target which
gives ronin ample opportunity to
approach her head on sure this leads to
a much-needed exposition dump but can we
have arrived in the same place without
making her look as ineffectual as these
guys
[Music]
okay this is a classic example of
something that looks badass but what the
hell was it actually supposed to do why
did it even bother deflecting it this
wouldn't have even slowed down hawkeye
but you're wondering how i found you
nope i'm wondering how clint got out of
his ronin costume where he stashed it in
how you managed to catch up at the
perfect moment who's that with my mom i
guess we're totally fine sharing
sensitive information while grylls is in
the room now yep totally cool with it
well that's the guy i've been worried
about this whole time
kingpin as this infuriating pronoun game
has concluded even the deep dark depths
of my dungeon of sin equity couldn't
block the elated screams of the internet
people permeating my person which can
only mean that it is supposed to be
somebody important that i should already
be aware of fine tell me what movie to
watch and i'll get caught up before the
finale three seasons of another tv show
that isn't on disney plus that may or
may not be partly or holy cannon son of
a [ __ ]
in a tough year for everyone marvel's
managed to give us something to look
forward to we've had a string of
adventures with characters we know and
love across five tv shows and 36
episodes of content thanks marvel of
course it also came with what feels like
seven years of previously ons and
opening credits so here's a sin instead
this bishop okay one immediate sin
removal for the masterful vincent
d'onofrio his kingpin [ __ ] rules that
said the show waited far too long to
introduce him as a villain which
undermined the respect his terror
deserves there are no lines in this
business but there should be because
without such lines lies a world where
meat grinders are attached to the edge
of desks and here's a random jug filled
with miniatures you know just in case
you forgot we were in a larper's house
and needed a reminder you
should go home you should be with your
family you can still make it in time for
christmas kate you're my partner nice
cinnamon and all but i feel like there's
not a widow's chance and end game that
he was leaving rather marvel just enjoys
toying with our emotions with this will
they won't they partner bullsh beaded
curtains turned on us okay let's have a
look at kingpin's abilities criminal
mastermind highly intelligent above
average strength and durability nope not
seeing telepathy anywhere so how the
hell did he see through maya's expert
level poker face and figure out she was
ready to betray him fletching soldering
danger spike poof powder clippers
callbacks label making excitement most
of these labels make sense but
icebreaker raises some questions how
often does hawkeye come up against ice
in such quantities as to require a
specific arrow either that or perhaps it
just provides interesting conversation
starters so if you're gonna do this i
just want to know you're ready and
short-term memory be damned as clint
appears to have forgotten that kate has
already been doing this in stating she
is well aware of the risk for all of the
some episodes fighting aliens with a
stick and a string okay kate we get it
he's willfully unequipped to be an
avenger lay off the guy already sheesh
even disney can't escape a comcast sin
what are assets what are threats dude
what about your assets okay there's no
chaeled no stark no cap but what about
sward spider-man or even ant-man or does
he only get to swap phone numbers when
he becomes an avenger himself it's a
weird flex but before title of my sex
tape mom said i was going to get your
wine collection kids i found her
touching your covert in your comms when
you speak that's the point of it being
discreet if you bring attention to the
damn thing every time you use it
i've never dodged a sniper's bullet
before so i don't mean to judge too
harshly here but would mr sniper have a
much harder time hitting you if you
crawled below the window as opposed to
above it just a thought what kind of
company decorates their prep area with
christmas decor like this do you think
the employees give a holly jolly [ __ ]
about lights draped across the room well
they do but only because the lights are
in the way of their serving dishes it's
your time bringing a sword to a sniper
fight i distinctly remember elena
telling kate to stay out of her way and
i can't understand why she avoids
incapacitating her immediately sure was
thoughtful of whoever opened all of the
doors in this series of adjacent rooms
so that we could watch the room to room
battle sequence sure the director of
photography thanks them for their
service
how did elena know that clint was going
to be at this window she knew he was on
the 12th floor but that still covers a
lot of windows if she didn't know and
still got it right then wow is this a
stroke of good luck only to be matched
by this shot missing clint hey you okay
yes but she should be a flattened and
super dead cape pancake a pancake
[Music]
does this really need an audible beep
wouldn't a silent beep always be
preferable no matter the mission i think
even penn and teller would struggle to
work out what kind of dark magic qazi
used to surprise hawkeye from out of
[ __ ] nowhere here dear henchman
thanks for not shooting clint
immediately love your friend the plot
this episode has been a hoot but i'll be
damned if show has time for this we're
trained professionals but that's not
enough right now are you [ __ ] kidding
me with this of course that's enough
what's the message here are you telling
the world to being a police officer or a
firefighter isn't enough in order to
help you have to be dressed up in a
costume and play hero isn't that exactly
the opposite of what hawkeye has been
saying this entire show hey bros kate
fires three arrows here but there are
five gun-toting tracksuit guys in total
were the other two seriously scared off
by a bow and arrow and a bit of high
ground kate
where's our back up the non-vengers here
managed to time this entrance so that it
immediately answered father clint
mistree's question also what about the
actual backup where the police are
multiple gunshots in a [ __ ] sniper at
rockefeller center not enough to draw in
new york's finest also also how many
people have been hurt or trampled in the
time it took these guys to suit up and
why do they think this will make the
public any more likely to take them
seriously than if they were dressed as
oh i don't know actual emergency service
people this acid arrow is all kinds of
the [ __ ] if it impacted the tree
here how did it manage to dissolve this
perfect wedge that would somehow require
the acid to know that it needs to
dissolve more of the outside of the tree
than the initial point of impact i'm
willing to believe that through
channeling his inner macgyver clint
managed to create an arrowhead absurdly
powerful enough to turn all of these
lampposts into electromagnets but an
electromagnet powerful enough to pull
guns from meters away would also likely
end up telling us far too much about who
has what pierced and where oh my god you
wore it you are surrounded why is this
costuming a thing right now this is not
humorous this is ridiculous you need to
get off this ice okay only off this size
is up those stairs well yeah if you're
insisting on walking out of there i mean
hawkeye managed to pack an arrow more
powerful than 20 mri machines but
somehow doesn't have one with a
grappling hook and rope to get them out
of this ice rink here
take these i have no idea which arrows
i'm giving you because i won't look at
the labels we made earlier but
regardless i have a feeling they will be
situationally specific to your exact
needs there's no denying that the acme
arrows are entertaining but are they
really worth the effort of all that home
brewing how are either of these arrows
any better than shooting the bad guys in
the legs with a regular arrow i mean
this guy's definitely looking at an
amputation and who knows what happened
to this poor bastard does that arrow
come with a parachute the biggest
problem with this fight is that it's
over if even two or three of these thugs
have a gun instead they just keep
running in a few at a time with a
variety of pipes and baseball bats so
that we can see our heroes make use of
the quiver of many things
what exactly was marv and harry's plan
here drive the van as fast as they can
hope they get enough air to fly into the
ice rink at best straight up killing
hawkeye and kate who they couldn't have
possibly been able to see or at worst
just killing themselves in a hideous
automotive mashup
kate actually did them a solid here
owl my
god kate your mom just came out the side
door thank you for that entirely
unhelpful description of which slide
door she could exit from on a massive
building with multiple points of
departure
[Music]
nice shot okay awesome call back and i
suppose none of this is particularly
impossible but you always have to ask
yourself wouldn't it be easier if like
wouldn't it be easier if hawkeye pulled
out another explodey arrow instead of
this trick shot that he himself admitted
to only having pulled off a few times or
wouldn't it be easier for qazi to step
to one side instead of relying on the
force or some to catch this arrow or
wouldn't it be easier to base your
superhero show around an actual
superhero prepare yourself for the
whiplash of several boss battles all
climaxing at the same time if you
thought the they survived this a-thon
was over you were wrong i need to know
what happened my goodness marvel loves
previously on segments so much it's
working one right into the middle of its
damn finale
strike
yeah keep the massive super strength
deadly boss in the room with you when
you should have and myself and thanos
mean this respectfully gone for the head
kate all of the survives all of this
this
freaking
[ __ ]
[Music]
works police arrived just in time to be
of no [ __ ] use to anybody in a finale
cliche
[Music]
oh
now you whistle to save your ass not
before when elena was whipping your face
with her thwacky beat stick she talked
about you all the time later we are with
hawkeye we're essentially avengers well
i suppose if they let hawkeye in you
took on kingpin all by yourself not many
people walk away from something like
that yeah you're telling us we're the
confused people who watch kate get
pummeled by kingpin and then walk away
like she just had an oopsie fall down a
teensy flight of cotton stairs
[Applause]
uh
my goodness i wish clint would make up
his damn mind about whether or not he
wants the ronin suit he gets rid of it
kate finds it he takes it from kate he
then leaves it in kate's burning
apartment then goes back to rescue it
and now he's burning it again honestly
this relationship is almost as
frustrating as steven bucky i said
almost can i ask you something if the
question is anything other than are we
breathing toxic fumes emitted from a
flaming suit that has been soaked in
your sweat and the blood of your enemies
should we be concerned then i'm adding
all the sins what do you think of lady
hawk oh oh no i think maybe i made this
full song extra credit scene exist
because of the sin from episode one and
i'm not sorry regardless i can sin this
all day
colonel
we got ourselves a broken arrow you
shouldn't use rob i want to know who i'm
looking at what did you say i bet she
didn't know i could do
better this playing in a tampon
commercial
hello
pardon
who
you're the little bishop girl what did
you call me
i called your name
the hell you did i'm sorry i'm sorry you
found out this way no no mom this is
this is just like
fast sex is a serious thing norman i
thought i was supposed to be the only
one working here well you're wrong
what's your name
i'm an old soul i like old music and old
movies and all even old people would a
bag of money know a place if the girl
says her name a man will feed her
tonight a girl has no name beginners
only get one free hit if you get here in
the torso it's fatal
let us gingerly touch our tips
[Music]
well i'm a viking i'm i'm really a
viking i don't care
you ready i was born ready stop letting
me win because i know something you
don't know i am not my friend
put one foot in front of the other baby
steps fear does not exist in this dojo
i seem to have fallen down a cliff i'm
still alive but i'm very badly injured
going and going and going
okay come out and play
[Music]
i drive a dodge stratus
just like budapest all over again you
and i remember budapest very differently
get off my train
what do you think
i think it's like a wax museum with a
pulse
thrown a couple of arms and
five minutes i think i need to start
over thing doesn't look natural
where does the hawk look
he looks in the barn he looks in the
attic he looks in a cellar he looks
everywhere he would hide
what
what did i say did i say something wrong
you put the wrong emphasis on the wrong
syllable
i will not look for you
i will not pursue you
but if you don't i will look for you
i will find you
and i will kill you
it's a movie marathon night right
check this
out have a few more trick arrow heads
you can't just put them on any shaft
no i am against innocent trees being cut
down in their prime and their their
corpses grotesquely dressed in like
tinsel and twinkly lights you can either
drive yourself home or i can have you
collected
who are you i
am the vengeance
window
yeah not going out the window
why are you scared marv are you afraid i
fart in your general direction your
mother was a hamster and your father
smelled of elderberries it's a synthetic
gas the counter agent to chemical
subjugation ate the antidote
it was at this moment that he knew
he [ __ ] up
[Music]
i met a man with seven wives every wife
had seven sacks every sack has seven
cats every cat has seven kittens kittens
cats sacks and wives how many were going
to sometimes
[Music]
you have failed this city well that's
the guy i've been worried about this
whole time
kingpin
[Music]
a man came in here earlier
a dead man and that means what to me
i believe he had an animal with him it
was a gift i gave him a pet cat
tony stark was able to build this in a
cave
with a box of scraps
before we get started
does anyone want to get out
[Music]
either one of you know where the
smithsonian is i'm here to pick up a
fossil
she sacrificed yourself
understand
you sacrifice yourself for me and not
even know her name sometimes family
doesn't see
eye to
eye i'm still alive but i'm very badly
injured it doesn't happen
too often but it's not that common it
doesn't happen to every guy and it is a
big deal